hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from Round four of the
OtterBox norway championship a lot of
you have requested it already it's a
Vishwanath on Island versus ding liran
and sorry about no video yesterday my
voice really wasn't cooperating today
it's a little bit better but still I
increase the volume of the microphone to
compensate for from you not speaking so
loudly and we already mentioned that
after round 3 there was a rest day so
that we will have some nice photos from
the rest day so here they are courtesy
of Leonard Otto's official photographer
of the OtterBox know with championship
here are all of the participants that
participated in the cooking contest all
the players of the OtterBox Noah
championship their assistants and the
judges that will be judging the meals
also here we have a very nice photo of
honor than Maxima sherrilyn Grove there
you can see a maxim being French Channel
he knows more than one way to prepare a
meal Anand cannot believe his eyes there
and here we have a nice photo of on the
decorating the plates because they you
know the judges judge more than just the
way you prepare the meal and here is a
nice photo of the meal they have
prepared with I don't know who the
person the left is but probably they're
probably their assistant or if you know
definitely do share in the comments so
that being said let's check out the game
and who do you think won the cooking
contest that is also the question so I
don't has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 and we will have a nice Italian
game but the 11 already played this game
in Shenzhen in April this year against
onigiri Giri had the white pieces but
we're gonna cover that as well not if
396 Bishop to c4 the Italian game Bishop
to c5 and here of course the Evans
gambit is a very nice opening but it was
not played in this game aren't just
castles we have nice to f6 and now d3 we
have castles biding c3 the six now and
rook to e1 so pretty much all standard
stuff
with a 5 and h3 now black also wants to
get a move in so h6 9 B to d2 this
Knight is then coming to f1 and then III
or g3 Bishop to e6 and our Bishop to b5
and here Queen to b8 with the idea now
that the DF dew point has been a
weakened you want to go
Queen to a7 and with this nice Queen
Bishop battery her as the f2 point and
this is the position onigiri had against
ding in the Shenzhen a few months back
where he played a bunch of captures on
c6 that game ended in a draw but here on
most nights to f1 so keeping everything
on the board I will still not mention if
this is a the classical or the
Armageddon but you know try to guess
judging by the moves and here there is a
one on game where lights to h5 was
played but here here it goes for Queen
to a7 immediately and it is over this
move move 11 that we have a completely
new game so what do you do here Queen to
d2 seemingly an odd move from Anandi
because you usually want to develop your
bishop first before bringing your Queen
into the game but Anand doesn't want to
trade pieces just yet and he has a
different plan
we have rook a to d8 biding and now
Knight the g3 we have nice day 17 also
wants to bring his Knight over 2 G 6 and
now d4 we have Bishop to b6 and now
Queen to c2 making room for the bishop
to be developed Knights the g6 biding
and now comes Bishop to e3 so a little
by little
Anand brings the bishop into the game
ended the Queen will return to the D 2
square we have a c6 pushing Iran's
Bishop back Bishop to b2 d3 ni Luke Fe a
something pretty much developed all of
his pieces and now Queen to d2 so now
the Queen and Bishop are optimally
placed and here ding says ok no more
waiting around I'm gonna break create a
you know a break in the center and we
have d5 so here there's a lot of tension
in the center and where you could
capture it here in a lot of ways Allen
finds the most interesting way to
capture here on run plays Bishop
captures on h6 and it's a very nice idea
because if the bishop is captured of
course the Queen comes to h6 and it will
be very hard for black to play this no
no good move will actually help the
black in this position whatever you play
like the D captures on e4 Knight
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
it's you know there aren't all that many
defenders around the black king the
Queen and Bishop are all the way on the
Queen side and here if you play Knight
f8 the guard eh 7 square just 95 and
then
there's no good defense against Uruk III
to g3 and whatever black does he will
suffer severe material losses on the
other hand if you play something like
each capture son before then again you
can have a nice series of crazy light
captures here Knight captures here
Bishop captures D captures and after
rook captures on e4 you could play G
captures mh-6 but again after Queen
captures on h6 yes you're up a piece but
again it's a very it's a very unpleasant
position to play a lot of a lot of nice
ideas for white in the position so here
at Bing finds a third idea he plays D
captures on e4 first
okay I'll replace Knight captures on e4
with Knight captures on e4 rook captures
on e4 and only now Bishop to d5 forces
the rook to move we have looked to g4 by
Anand and now II for closing the bishop
so you might think what is undoing here
all of his pieces are hanging this is
just this is just insane but Allen has
everything everything planned out
Knights the h4 so what do you do here of
course if you capture then you lose the
game Roe captures here is pretty much
over you have to go to h8 Queen come to
g5 and the black is falling apart so
here after Knight to h4 ding plate 8
capture some d3 it's the best move and
now what do you do here it's really
really an interesting question because
the best move recommended by the engine
is Knight captures on g6 the problem
with Knight captures on g6 is that it's
a force to draw after F captures here
you will play rock captures threaten
here after a rogue defense the g7 point
you will just capture and after captures
captures and captures Queen g5 check
insurance the white a draw by repetition
as he's done so much material he can't
go for much more king of 7 Queen h5
check you're not allowed to go to the
e-file because then you allow rook e1
check so you have to go back in a faith
while keeping an eye on your rook here
Queen h8 check you will have to repeat
thing of seven Queens I'm checking your
faith King Queen h8 and it will be a
draw by repetition so here although
after each capture son d3 Knight
captures here is the strongest move
recommended by the engine it's one of
those cases where it's not enough to
play the strongest move here an invoice
for Knight to f5
and the Knight to f5 is actually a move
that loses the game for Anand so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure out why it loses the game for
Anand I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are in you know
excellent solver of positions that never
occurred in the game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
the move is rook to e2 so just a very
nice move that forces the Queen to
capture on d3 after the Queen captures
can be three now you play Queen to a6 so
if you found this route rookie to Queen
to a6 just a beautiful line you will be
done material so you can't really trade
Queens and if you move the Queen Queen
g3 then you play G captures on h6 and
now after all is said and done rope
captures on g6 of course Queen captures
and g6 King f8 now you would have some
very nice threats here but the black has
a rock on it too
so for example if you're between g7
checking yet you will not have Queen e7
mate but also you cannot bring the rook
over to e1 the rook on e to make sure
both of those threats are not really
possible so here black will just start
bringing his pieces into the game and
the white will be lost so this is a the
move dink had had an option of playing
rookie too but it didn't hear ding
played Bishop to e6 and now now this is
a move that loses the game for dink so
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the the best move for
our not here in this position I'll give
you a couple of seconds while I have a
nice sip of my water for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just gotten a a morphe head
whoa not not for ding this time this
time the morphe head goes to Anand
because here aren't placed the shove
capture some g7 and it's just just a
very nice concept here whatever you do
it doesn't really help you being
accepted the knight Bishop captures done
at 5 but now we have Queen h6 and now
how do you prevent all of all of the
nice meeting ideas the main the main
idea is of course rook captures on g6
followed by Queen to HHH checkmate so
just removing the defender of the HH HH
square and delivering
checkmate the problem is if you play
Bishop captures here you get Bishop to
f6 and there's no stopping mate on g7 so
ding of course saw this and he decided
to go for rooked east six now next move
he can capture on g4 he's guarding the
the night here with the rook also you
know if route captures he can capture
with the pawn create some square for his
King here but here again it's a forced
mate so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best move for Anand in
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent
checkmater in five and for those of you
who just won enjoyed show the move is
Bishop to h8 and it was in this position
and move 27th at ding quieren resigned
the game here we can remove the morphe
head now and yes for those of you who
are wondering this was an Armageddon
game which is a very interesting because
if this was a classical game in that
position that we've talked about and
would have gone for Bishop before Knight
captures on g6 and he would have
accepted the draw by repetition but here
he needed the win he had the white
pieces in Armageddon so he decided to go
for the funky Knight a5 line and it
turned out excellent rob idea here
there's just no defense against the
Queen to g7 mate III said was made him 5
because here you would have to give up
some of your pieces that the problem
made but you know that's with best
defense but it's really just Queen g7
mate so there's there's no way around
this but yeah like I said a very
interesting moment that tonight captures
on g6 I don't had no reason of playing
it because it was a forced draw so he
found the man another line and this is
why I founded this game so so beautiful
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it we're gonna show at least one more
game and I also have one more suggestion
from you guys I'm not gonna mention it
so you don't check it out yourself
you know you might spoil it for you but
yeah I would like to thank Brian coral
berry McMurdo Benjamin Garcia
mr. bish and Michael sharp for a
contribution for my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the ulti box Norway
championship
and we're gonna check out one more game
from this round to check out the
standings and so on I think I'll I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day